no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ciao a tutti per venerdì 3 assi nuova
challenge non c'entro che non è come
parlarsi volo verso il cioccolato
abbiamo già fatto un'analisi del jazz
propone scatole e dentro c'erano slime
ben 30 g di slide o schifosi o belli che
lei dice è stata una cosa divertente o
meno di tale perché avuto fortuna ma io
no poi lasciano anche di questo video se
volete vederla in queste sale invece di
esserci risplendere in tre ci saranno
gli ingredienti del pit line
potremmo di rendereste tenerife zambiani
senza sapere cosa c'è dentro una volta
decideremo cosa mettere dentro le cross
è l'altra persona dovrà ben darsi poi la
persona che non sa cosa c'è dentro la
tela si deciderà se tenerlo o scambiarli
mente from vita mi sono dimenticata
ovviamente ben tre si sono gli
ingredienti noi abbiamo già la nostra
con la trasparenza e qua
dell'ingrediente alla cosa trasferiti
presenta le dita utili da tutti
ingredienti che sono andati a male o si
è andati benissimo ma l'etica allora
devi anche tappati le orecchie camera in
canzoncina non senti il canto del conte
di cavour giugno ci vedo cantato dolore
canta ma cosa la targhetta l'affrettata
per le orecchie da parte di senza casa
ok fa tuttavia bella bellissima la sua
canzone vicinali complimenti allora non
tiene scambi roso sentire l'energia pari
con i cani fammi pensare secondo re
siccome è il primo che mi ha dato una
schifezza però potrebbe anche essere un
plesso primi sette l'hotel grande
risposta affermativa anche 32 non è
scaduto liberarmi ho io
[Musica]
giusto speriamo che non sia già verde
deliziosa modelli che mettono un
consiglio ma che puzza che sta colorando
bene delizioso diventato bianco giardino
chissà poi quando andrà ad attivarlo
benissimo mandarmi capitale scegliere
ingredienti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
prati fatto tappa lo chiederemo scambi
lo scambio
[Musica]
3 2 1
bravo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ciao
il professionismo a 48 pozzo ha chiamato
il tutto rimanendo maionese perché
aggiunge zavoli piacevole lo interessava
perché in dico che se amiamo edizione
non so fino a qualche altra vivente
facciamo diventare mente quel gusto dai
fantastici praticamente nella mia
collezione di sla e questo mi piace a
due all'ora coscienza radioattivo male
ma posso trafitti da tra l'altro perché
sono super raffreddato
siamo pronti togli la maschera
[Musica]
condottieri scavi scambio che prima
l'ultima ottenuto da loria
magari mi confrontarmi carico per la
puzza della maglianese va bene non c'è
ancora lo zaino torna cosi a diventare
aperto lucente non decidano notti magari
lo vediamo in ai miti la colazione
maionese
[Musica]
perché non in bolle 2 stato e perché la
maionese si sta emozionando per dare
[Musica]
allora devo dire che il colore è
veramente bello è schifoso vedremo il
mio slide verde grazie a te papa e poi
qua o l'olio buio vediamo dove tibetane
che si fa
[Musica]
oddio stranissimo quando sta sciogliendo
che sta succedendo mi sta separando il
tempo effettivo queste si attiva è
diventato sta diventando superfici dove
sbaglio sì è vero magari è una tecnica
per farlo diventare super e iper iper
grossi o magari si rovinano tutto
vedremo noi abbiamo vicino alla fine
perché poi ragazzina che viene sfruttato
gli spedirono per frizzanti ma ricercata
[Musica]
i carichi tiene anche siamo
fatto io quando lo conosco quando la
parola prodi imparare
potete dirmi capelli
[Musica]
mm oggi la tengo io scrivo da guarda al
marito e al mese sente il pepe lo slime
fatto come telecapri la cosa forse non
assegnerà oscar nel cervelletto
stringermi secondo me di non cominciare
molto perché deve stare un po in
infusione se no come fa in infusione a
logiche di per studi che abbia mai
andato per uno slidephone n siamo pronti
per la nostra infusione quanti minuti
deve stare a 5 il tennis live coloniale
è vero che anche l'olio dispiace primo
di scegliere per se devo aprirla magari
dopo quando lo attiviamo con la
situazione da vicino
provo a lasciarlo un po sì sì lasciamo
con infusione già metodi un po di colore
certo io non lo sta che buono problema
beh no posso fare una battuta la battuta
cattiva mette perdere bene così lo
facciamo diventare ma io direi che basta
un bel omega violet e non si vede più
niente e supersoft richiama l'odore che
per tanti anni ha già messo a cantare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
caldo
è fatto ok forse la maschera
attenzione questo round dobbiamo
prendere devi prendere radici quelle
giuste
[Musica]
la spezia mentale
mi sa che ottengo questo no io so che
cosa diversa
marc webb di stan bracco noi che abbiamo
da un po di tempo perché ne abbiamo
cucinato troppi e quello ne sono molti
che li ma dobbiamo sentire barattolino
ma quindi abbiamo più amata che adesso
non ottenere aprile stilato una bozza
che inonderà tutta la casa e rimarrà
alle paesi per una settimana per
fermarli perfette il milan
io sono sean
[Musica]
le immagini che tornerà giostraio
godibilissimo come i romanisti mercato
sono super buon libro
diciamo che parla dal frigo dalla 45 ma
per profumi secondo me forse meglio se
cominci primato perché quando apro
questi secondo mese fa scappare
allora io vabbè tranne che c'è il tempo
ha dentro però albero è l'unico
ingrediente brutto allora a parte che io
non so come faccia rischiarlo e ad
attivarlo con il tempo ha testato questa
l'ufficio giriamo l'attenzione dopo
dentro ammettere cosa la bottiglia dico
è che cosa si
[Musica]
ma io non so come farò ad attivarlo
bassline forse si romperà tutto che
vuole 30 raccontata male fargli vedere
bene i propri lavori legati a mio avviso
tantissimo posso dire una cosa puzza di
scoreggia
[Risate]
si restringe la puzza terribile e mi
sembra che il live tratto nel nostro ne
so proprio quale sia la bracco alla juve
di un party a mettere i vostri
broccoletti di
sento il capo l'odore siamo tuttora
esperta mamma mia forza la colla riesce
a coprire l'odore non erano ne erano
andati male sti broccoli di più ma è
normale il propoli puntano dopo un po è
passato tanto tempo
lì pronto ad attivare il tuo bellissimo
slime è a toccarlo diciamo che sfigati
il mio blackberry è vero peccato sia
meglio essere ri siano attivati a tutti
perché si tratta lo slider risucchiava
di anch'io che trova etica albero di
natale ecco qua il mio snai
è venuto molto carina devo dire anche se
verde una sorta di verde pastello buono
aiutato molto a far disperdere il colore
e qui molto grossi non so se sia grazie
all'olio comunque la consistenza
chicchissima e super carica con questi
panini piola è in rotta sei contento del
risultato della prima ma ciò che ho
detto aspetta
guarda che è successo si arrotola si
sposano per tutto sembra terra oddio
cosa devo fare
volumi di forza sparisce il life ball
per verde
ma impressione sembra tipo una tana
delle formiche non so cosa succede di
continuo a fischiarla si spargerà
dappertutto ma che per due prove
addio no non è milano ma due no ceca
l'etichetta proviamo a tirarlo via più
di tre ore è bruttissimo possono
sembrare decorazioni neri una frittata e
verdura metropoli che fine hanno fatto
sono tutti i rock
si va in giro staccati il proprio una
frittata spettatore di popoli ma la
lettiga to penice branco solco di sinisi
riguarda si stacchino mezzo ma si sta
sta con la paletta è ma guarda che lo
devi anche toccare con le mani è tutto
perché finalità fare con un'altezza la
challenge non puoi farlo proprio la
paletta boca
no perché puzza quando volevo che però
poi ti faccio un bel massaggio con le
mazzate devi toccarlo dei tocca la tocca
[Risate]
l'obiettivo ha giocato ma di far bene in
pochi la fretta di broccoli questi
broccoli pizarro solo tre date poi un po
di pochi in questo aspetto perché lo
vedo un po pericoloso
hai paura che si rimanga per tempo
incastrato nella vita si dettino che
punta che potrà mettiamo un po di
attivatore perché
[Musica]
si sta attaccando tutto sulla vita già
allora speriamo perché se picchiano e
lui che gradisce in canna
si chiede di non si spara distaccato
questa è la tua maledizione trucco per
sempre fatte line broccone oggi sz
carafa alla fine visto attraverso più
non ci credo ma come candidati farlo e
non lo so ma è troppo che si ribella
alla fine il mio agente contanti pallini
neri per le ditte che poking che a vita
diciamo che è veramente veramente raro
si ok allora non è certo uno dei miei
isla in più belli no però mi dovete
votare per il coraggio perché malato
coraggioso come questo con questo con
questo slide coloso puzzolente ad
omettere di colonna la mano in me la
immerge nella stazione per me è sacro e
poi nel sapore per farlo ricordo che il
mio bellissimo libro non tantissime
ricette fermo non sono pagate anche da
parte qui dispero delle idee del
challenge e ora scontato che in
descrizioni anche voi
e allora mila sabato caterina cliccare
per vedere i nostri dati video nella
stessa giunta renzi mini divertenti
clive jones con a ruota pubblicamente
operari preferite e buona